DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
CHRIS.
>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM RENO, NEVADA.
MARK, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SENIOR ADVISOR STEVE CORTES.
STEVE, AS WE JUST REPORTED IN
THE LATEST FOX POLL, THE
ECONOMY.
SO FAR THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
BROKEN THROUGH, STEVE.
>> Steve: WELL, I THINK HE IS
BREAKING THROUGH ON THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE, WHICH IS THE
ECONOMY.
DOES A LOT OF
SINGULAR BUT I STILL BELIEVE
THAT THE ULTIMATE DRIVER OF THE
ELECTORAL DECISION FOR MOST
AMERICANS IS GOING TO BE WHAT IT
TYPICALLY IS, WHO CAN CREATE
PROSPERITY FOR ME, FOR MY
FAMILY, AND FOR THIS COUNTRY
GOING FORWARD AND ON THAT SCORE
THE PRESIDENT HAS A COMPELLING
STOR JANUARY 20TH, THE PRESIDENT
GOT HIS PRESIDENTIAL DAILY
BRIEF, THE TOP INTELLIGENCE IN
THE DASH AT THAT POINT ROBERT
O’BRIEN SAID THIS IS THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE YOU ARE GOING TO FACE
AND YOUR ENTIRE PRESIDENCY AND
THE DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, MATTHEW, IMMEDIATELY
COMPARED IT TO THE SPANISH BLUE,
THE DEADLY SPANISH BLUE OF 100
YEARS AGO, SO THERE WAS NO FOG
OF WAR THERE.
IF THE WORD HE WAS GETTING FROM
HIS TOP INTELLIGENCE AND
NATIONAL SECURITY PEOPLE WAS
THAT THIS WAS A DEADLY PANDEMIC.
THERE WAS NO FOG HERE.
IF >> Steve: THERE WAS
TREMENDOUS FOG, AND LET ME TELL
YOU WHY.
THAT WAS THEIR VIEW, YOU’RE
EXACTLY RIGHT BUT DR. FAUCI,
SOMEONE WAS LIONIZED -- SOMEONE
WHO WAS CLEARLY
WERE SHIFTING DRAMATICALLY AMONG
THE SCIENTISTS, AMONG THE
POLITICIANS THIS ENTIRE TIME AS
WE WERE TRYING TO LEARN ABOUT
THE VIRUS.
DR. FAUCI SAID THAT AND DAYS
LATER, LITERALLY, HE WAS
ADVOCATING FOR A NATIONAL
SHUTDOWN, SOMETHING THAT THAT
HAPPENED TWO WEEKS LATER IN THE
MIDDLE OF MARCH, SO I THINK IT’S
UNFAIR FOR YOU TO CHARACTERIZE
THINGS AS IF THEY WERE SOLID AND
UNCHANGING.
THESE WERE SHIFTING FACTS,
SHIFTING ANALYSES, AND BY THE
WAY, PART OF WHY WE KNEW SO
LITTLE IS BECAUSE THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, THE ULTIMATE
CULPRIT IN ALL OF THIS, NOT
DONALD TRUMP, NOT THE DEMOCRATS,
NO AMERICAN, THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY LIED TO THE
WORLD.
THEY COULD HAVE SHARED THE
SCIENTIFIC AND HEALTH
INFORMATION WITH THE WORLD EARLY
ON AND IN ALL LIKELIHOOD EITHER
CONTAINED THIS VIRUS TO WUHAN
ITSELF, OR IF IT DID GET OUT OF
ONE, AT LEAST HELP THE WORLD TO
DEAL WITH IT EFFECTIVELY.
INSTEAD, WE WERE CIRCLING
LARGELY IN THE DARKNESS TO TRY
AND FIGURE OUT THE SCIENTIFIC
FACTS -- AND AGAIN, THE
SCIENTISTS THEMSELVES WERE
SHIFTING THEIR VIEWS
DRAMATICALLY DURING THIS PERIOD.
>> Chris: STEVE, YOUR
EXPLANATION IS SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT FROM THE PRESIDENT,
BECAUSE YOU ARE SAYING WELL, THE
PRESIDENT DIDN’T REALLY KNOW, IT
WAS THE FOG OF WAR, BUT WHEN HE
HAS DESCRIBED IT, HE SAID HE
DIDN’T WANT TO PANIC THE
COUNTRY, HE DIDN’T WANT TO JUMP
UP AND DOWN AND PANIC THE
COUNTRY.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THERE’S
A QUESTION ABOUT THAT IS BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
PLAYS THE PANIC CARD ALL THE
TIME, ESPECIALLY WHEN HE’S
TALKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF BIDEN WINS, THE MOB WINS.
IF BIDEN WINS, THE RIOTERS,
ANARCHISTS, ARSONISTS, AND FLAG
BURNERS WIN.
>> PEACEFUL PROTESTS.
PEACEFUL PROTEST.
>> Chris: IS THAT A PRESIDENT
WHO IS TRYING TO KEEP THE
COUNTRY CALM?
>> Steve: THERE’S A KEY
DIFFERENCE HERE.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING
ABOUT LEGITIMATE FEAR OF WHAT
CAN HAPPEN IN AMERICA IF
JOE BIDEN WERE TO WIN, AND IF
DISRESPECT FOR THE POLICE WERE
CONTINUE TO BECOME THE NORM IN
THIS COUNTRY, HE’S TRYING TO
EXHORT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
ACTION, TO SAY WE CAN STOP THIS,
WE CAN BACK THE POLICE, WE CAN
RESTORE ORDER, WE CAN INSIST ON
THE RULE OF LAW.
THAT IS SENSIBLE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS LEGITIMATE FEAR
OUT THERE IN THE COUNTRY.
WHAT IS NOT HELPFUL IS TO TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THIS
VIRUS IS OUT OF CONTROL, BECAUSE
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN?
THINGS LIKE HOARDING, WHICH IS
HAPPENING ANYWAY AT THAT TIME.
IT WAS ALL READY COMMENCING.
THE PRESIDENT’S JOB IN A TIME OF
CRISIS IS PARTLY TO BE
REASSURING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, TO CONVINCE THEM THAT WE
CAN AND WILL PERSEVERE THROUGH
THIS EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
PEARL HARBOR, AND THAT’S WHAT HE
DID.
HE WAS REASSURED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AT THE SAME TIME HE WAS
TAKING DECISIVE ACTION.
HE DIDN’T JUST OFFER FLOWER
PHRASES AND SETBACK.
NO, HE REASSURED THE PEOPLE --
>> Chris: OKAY -- STEVE, I GOT
YOUR POINT.
THE ARGUMENT WOULD BE THAT IT’S
A FALSE CHOICE YOU’RE MAKING.
HE EITHER PLAYS THE ROSY
SCENARIO OR HE SETS HIS HAIR ON
FIRE.
THERE WAS SOMETHING IN THE
MIDDLE, WHICH IS JUST BEING
HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THERE’S A QUESTION, STEVE,
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT IS STILL BEING HONEST
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WANT TO PLAY WHAT HE AND
DR. FAUCI SAID THIS WEEK ABOUT
HOW LONG THE CORONAVIRUS IS
GOING TO BE WITH US.
HERE THEY ARE.
>> WE ARE ROUNDING THE TURN.
YOU SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING, YOU
SEE THE NUMBERS ARE PLUNGING.
>> IF YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
GETTING BACK TO A DEGREE OF
NORMALITY, WHICH RESEMBLES WHERE
WE WERE PRIOR TO COVID, IT’S
GOING TO BE WELL INTO 2021,
MAYBE EVEN TOWARDS THE END OF
2021.
>> Chris: THOSE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT MESSAGES.
WE ARE ROUNDING THE TURN VERSUS
THE END OF 2021 ABOUT HOW LONG
THE VIRUS IS GOING TO BE WITH US
US.
>> Steve: SURE.
CLEARLY THE PRESIDENT HAS A FAR
MORE OPTIMISTIC VIEW RIGHT NOW
THEN DOES DR. FAUCI, BUT LET ME
ALSO POINT OUT EVEN WITHIN THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY THERE’S
TREMENDOUS DEBATE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE’S PEOPLE LIKE
DR. ATLAS FROM STANFORD, A LOT
OF FOLKS WITHIN SCIENCE WHO
WOULD DISAGREE WITH DR. FAUCI.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW MAKING I
THINK VERY PROPERLY OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC CASE THAT WE ARE
NEARING THE END OF THIS, THAT
THE TRENDS ARE GOING
AGGRESSIVELY TOWARDS HEALTH AND
REGARDING FAUCI, BY THE WAY,
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS CRITICAL
ON THE ISSUES, FAUCI ON YOUR
NETWORK JUST A FEW DAYS AGO MADE
IT VERY CLEAR THAT HE DOESN’T
BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT WAS BEING
DISHONEST AND LET ME BE PRECISE"
IMPERATIVE HE SAID, THIS IS
DR. FAUCI TALKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT, HE SAID I DIDN’T SEE
ANY DISCREPANCIES.
AT WHAT HE TOLD US, WHAT WE TOLD
HIM AND WHAT HE CAME OUT AND
SAID PUBLICLY.
AND AGAIN, NOBODY IS GOING TO
ACCUSE DR. FAUCI OF BEING A
TRUMP ARTISAN.
HE SAID NO DISCREPANCIES HERE.
>> Chris: IN A NARROW ON MSNBC
ON FRIDAY HE SAID SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
SOMETIMES YOU’RE CITING HIM AS
AN AUTHORITY AND SOMETIMES
YOU’RE SAYING HE’S WRONG.
I’VE GOT ONLY TIME FOR THIS ON
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Steve: I JUST OF THE
PRESIDENT HAD A MORE OPTIMISTIC
VIEW.
I DIDN’T SAY FAUCI IS WRONG, I
SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS A MORE
OPTIMISTIC VIEW ABOUT THE VIRUS
RIGHT NOW.
>> Chris: DR. FAUCI IS THE
LEADING INFECTIOUS DISEASE
EXPERT IN THIS COUNTRY.
SCOTT ATLAS, WHO YOU REFERRED
TO, WASN’T EVEN AN INFECTIOUS
DISEASE EXPERT, HE’S A
RADIOLOGIST.
>> Steve: THERE WAS A RANGE OF
VIEW IN THE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT’S JOB IS NOT TO
JUST TAKE THE ADVICE ONLY OF
SCIENTISTS AS IF THAT IS THE
ONLY INPUT THAT MATTERS.
IT’S A CRITICAL INPUT,
ABSOLUTELY, INTO MAKING POLICY,
BUT AS FOR OTHER CONSIDERATIONS,
PHYSICAL HEALTH BUT ALSO MENTAL
HEALTH, THE ECONOMIC VITALITY OF
OUR COUNTRY, NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Chris: WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT --
YOUR CHANGING THE SUBJECT.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
QUESTION OF HOW LONG THE VIRUS
IS GOING TO BE WITH US.
ONE LAST QUESTION ABOUT THE
CAMPAIGN, AND THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE ISSUE OF EARLY
MAIL-IN VOTING, BECAUSE AT THIS
POINT YOU SEEM TO BE LOSING THAT
RACE, AND LET ME PUT UP SOME
NUMBERS.
IN KEY SWING STATES, FLORIDA AND
NORTH CAROLINA AND PENNSYLVANIA,
DEMOCRATS LEAD REPUBLICANS BY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
REQUESTS FORM BALLOTS IN TWO OF
THOSE THREE STATES BY MORE THAN
2:1.
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT TALKING
DOWN MAIL AND VOTING, STEVE, AND
THE FACT THAT YOU’VE GONE
LARGELY DARK IN A LOT OF THESE
STATES IN TERMS OF TV ADS,